today we're going to be speaking with
greg tucker kellogg who's a biology
professor at the national university of
singapore he also has a youtube channel
addressing scientific misinformation on
social media of which there is
a lot right now a great really great to
have you on greg i appreciate it
well thanks thanks for having me so i
want to eventually work towards
ivermectin which you've been talking
about quite a bit on your channel but
maybe first we could talk a little bit
about you know since the early days in
the pandemic there there have been these
kind of clusters of um uh
treatment ideas that are proposed and i
want to be careful how i how i describe
them because just because something is
proposed as a treatment doesn't mean it
is a treatment for covid and early on it
was hydroxychloroquine
azithromycin
maybe vitamin d although vitamin d was i
think proposed more prophylactically
than some of these other things and
eventually ivermectin was added to the
list
generally speaking my idea has been that
most of the proposed so-called
treatments
are cheap ubiquitous
things
which are mostly available in much of
the world and that so in some sense it
makes sense that we would at least ask
might these things be used be useful is
that a fair assessment of how some of
these things start
absolutely so there's a whole area of
drug discovery and drug development
that's referred to as drug repurposing
and so the idea is to take drugs that
are available for other purposes and to
see if they can be
based well repurposed and and found
utility in something like an emergency
like covet
and so there were lots of tests around
the world and actually large screening
programs there was a fairly large
screening program at the nih for example
that was screening through approved
drugs
to see whether they would have activity
in various viral assays
and
those screening programs eventually you
know
they generated some interest and there
were some follow-ups but yeah there's
there's
a lot of interest in seeing whether some
of those things can be can be used and
of course steroid treatments are now a
mainstay of um of treatment for for
covid19 so um some of that has been
really really useful when this is done
are are really expensive drugs sometimes
tested and what i mean by that is i
haven't heard of expensive cancer drugs
being tested to see might that work for
covid for example i mean is it typically
the cheap stuff
um well it's typically
everything that's approved
because one of the one of the things one
would like to be able to do with a drug
in particular is to be able to skip the
the safety trials so if you know if you
already know that it's safe then that's
fine but actually in the case of cancer
you know a lot of traditional cancer
drugs are like chemotherapeutics are
effectively poisonous and so it's not so
much the price but you know there are
other reasons not to give them to
something to say a covet patient
so in terms of the appropriate way to
determine whether a drug works to treat
a disease like kovid in the last two
years we've seen every iteration from
a french doctor
gave hydroxychloroquine to 38 people and
here's sort of like his sense of how
they did
uh all the way to some actual randomized
controlled trials
for ivermectin comparing it to
the standard of care
uh versus a placebo et cetera so talk a
little bit about sort of like the ideal
formulation of the way we would test
something for covid
um sure well i i'll speak to like the
drug discovery and clinical trial
aspects of it so when one
does you know drug discovery when one
does
uh clinical trials you you like to
uh to to treat or to test new drugs or
drugs for a new purpose in a way that is
relevant so sometimes
it might be pre-clinical studies
screening for large numbers and then as
you get to more expensive studies like
clinical trials you move to smaller
groups so there's uh some of the most
important trials in this
have been what they call platform trials
where they're looking at
a large number of different agents so
the together trial for example
um is such a platform trial and they
look at a number of agents there's been
some really good things that have come
out with this but it's not just
you know it's not just everything in the
kitchen sink you have to you know make
choices judiciously with the evidence
that you have and move forward with the
things that have the most promise
in general
when we have now when we're two years in
to this pandemic
there is somewhat of an accepted
standard of care for how moderate to
severe covid is treated in hospital
settings so if we want to introduce the
idea of measuring the effect of
something like ivermectin
would we always be testing it against
the standard of care rather than against
nothing because few people would just
get nothing is that an important aspect
of this
yeah so in um
right so in clinical trials there's
there's a principle of equipoise where
you you don't want to give an inferior
treatment you know ethically you want to
know that you're giving at least the
standard of care
obviously if there is no standard of
care then that's another situation but
if you
have a standard of care you want to be
giving it uh also of course as over the
last year as a lot of people have gotten
vaccinated
and as people have had prior infections
so there's some
protection from immunity and that also
complicates trials there's lots of
things that complicate trials over time
but certainly you want to give
you don't want to
deny the standard of care to somebody in
a clinical trial and again in an ideal
formulation with something like
ivermectin would you really want three
groups one group that is just the
standard of care group and everybody
knows they're not receiving ivermectin
and then you would have a placebo group
and an ivermectin group and they don't
know whether they are receiving the
ivermectin is that was would that be the
ideal setup
so in the
in the first case the chart talking
about where you know people know you
know so it's generally two groups it's
two arms
in in one particular setting even of a
platform trial so in a platform trial
they might be looking at multiple
different settings um
but you want to be able to compare the
people who are getting the standard of
care and the people who are getting the
standard of care and then maybe some new
agent
fair um a few weeks ago you did a great
interview with jaka befemenko
about a study or conference abstract as
maybe it's better referred to on
ivermectin i did a much less detailed a
sec segment on that and this was one
that really caught fire everybody from
jordan peterson to
uh dr john campbell who i i don't say
this pejoratively he's not a medical
doctor i i just i feel driven to say
that because there's some confusion
about about his credentials initially
said wow 70 reduction in mortality for
people given ivermectin you extensively
broke that down including with one of
the authors of the conference abstract
who said this was retrospective
observational data we don't know about
dosing the groups weren't separated by
vaccine status there's all these other
problems with this why do you think that
caught such fire on social media because
the result was just notable and it made
a great headline
yeah so um i mean i'm learning a lot
about how this
misinformation uh
train works and ivermectin seems to be
the grift that keeps on grifting
and
uh
so what happens is in this case it was
just a conference abstract but it had
this
kind of startling result or a result
that could be spun in a way that was
startling and seemed dramatic
and so that little thing gets amplified
into something much larger and then
the results that are presented in the
cons in the conference abstract were
then taken way out of context and
misrepresented in in other ways and
all the limitations of the conference
abstract which led to it not being
published
they weren't talked about and so it just
seemed like it was something much much
larger much more definitive than it was
and that is what keeps happening over
and over again
i uh have no you know i think one of the
sad things about this is it's very easy
to say this stuff has become politicized
and and in a certain sense it it has
but i'm not aware of people who don't
want ivermectin or hydroxyl or zpax to
work i mean it i would love it if we had
evidence that something really cheap and
widely available was effective so i feel
like it's it's not uniformly or
symmetrically politicized i just want to
be able to say
we have or we don't have evidence that
this works but it really does seem
particularly here in the united states
that there are people who attach to any
one of these ideas and
they almost stop caring about what the
data show
yeah so it's it's frustrating so i'm not
a medical doctor either i'm a scientist
i'm a i'm a biologist a biophysicist by
training yes and
the
uh it's it's frustrating because
what's happening in in this case is that
people are latching onto these and then
they're
they're latching on to things that have
not been shown to be effective
instead of
moving forward with things that are
effective that have been shown to be
effective and that's the real tragedy of
this because they keep latching on to it
and i think it's actually not just i
wouldn't say it's a failure of science
so in the case of ephemeko it was not a
failure of science science worked they
decided not to publish the paper
but it was a terrible failure of science
communication
and that's what keeps happening so the
the the misuse tends to exploit the
ignorance
of people about how science
communication works it kind of widens
that gap so people don't know what a
conference abstract is and then they
take that
lack of knowledge the public lack of
knowledge and just
you know
build on it
in thinking back now to that earlier
list that i mentioned of the ideas that
there were early in the pandemic and if
you're not prepared to go into this that
that's fine i'm kind of springing this
on you it seems that
the vitamin d piece
has had some favorable results where
compared to a placebo
generally speaking
the correct level of vitamin d
has a generally protective effect it's
not a treatment for covid but it seems
as though what we suspected about
vitamin d that if you're if your level
is low you're more susceptible to
illness
that seems to have been confirmed right
i mean that that seems one of the early
things we learned
so i think there was a lot of um there
was a lot of conflicting data on this as
well there was encouraging signs but
there was just a large study published
i think within the last week and i have
the study on my two read list but i
haven't read it and
it doesn't show any benefit oh it does
have vitamin d you know yeah so it's a
negative result
um for vitamin d
and is that for supplementation
generally or just looking at if you're
deficient versus you're not you might be
better or worse off so this is where
we're get i wish i had read the study
now right i haven't read the study so i
don't want to misspeak on that fair but
but that seems to be a fundamental
question i guess that should be answered
yeah so in the case of vitamin d i think
the the argument had been
uh that perhaps a deficiency would have
been something to address but then that
that doesn't mean anything about
supplementation
right so if you're if you're not
deficient then
supplementation wouldn't necessarily be
assumed to have any have any benefit and
in this case i honestly i haven't read
the study results so very um i i don't
want to misrepresent it oh you teach in
singapore i'm curious if you can kind of
give us some insights as to whether
the entire media and social media
landscape around these discussions is
different there than in the united
states which which has been completely
out of control and rife with
misinformation and disinformation what
what's the sort of feel there of these
discussions
uh in social media or the news media
either that you feel comfortable
commenting on
sure well i mean the news media is
pretty tame
here um and uh so that so there's not
much in in the news media in the social
media there's been some there's actually
been a pro
ivermectin group and and as often
happens the fellow travelers in this
tend to be anti-vax and so there's uh
they've been pro-ivermectin anti-vaxx
anti-mandate and
and some of uh some of them have gotten
into legal trouble um and that's they've
used social media telegram groups
facebook groups and so on to uh to
basically work um
to do their work and spread their
message and in fact in some sense that's
how i got into this because
somebody had been influenced by these
groups and
asked me for help asked me to help her
understand these things and kind of
ultimately
she ended up getting a vaccine but it
took a while
well the youtube channel is excellent
you really break these things down in a
way that is both detailed but also
accessible which i think is so important
right now when we talk about science
communication i want to suggest to
everybody in my audience check out greg
tucker kellogg's youtube channel greg is
a biology professor at the national
university of singapore really
appreciate your time today
well thanks very much david really nice
talking to you